this is my slightly overdue dr. Sadler
channel updates video for March and
April of 2014 we're now about a week
into April so some of the things I'm
going to talk about with respect to
April have already happened but I'm
going to lump them in there anyway
before that there's two things I would
like to talk about that are particularly
cool and that I'm very happy about one
of these is that I've received a few
very nice donations recently i have a
link in some of the videos particularly
the the half-hour hagel videos and
that's what these were actually about
they said you know I like what you're
doing with the half-hour hagel I'd like
to support your work here you go and
there's also the tip jar which you can
see on my main page and you know I get a
lot of positive feedback in general in
terms of comments and that's very nice
but it's also very nice to have some
sort of remuneration for it so i have to
say thank you to these people for
expressing their gratitude i have to
express my own gratitude and turn I'm
not going to name any names but you can
expect to receive a nice email from me
later on today as I get caught up on on
things so there is there's data there
the donations was a kind of a cool thing
around the turn of the month and then
something else that happened in youtube
and also on my face book author page is
we passed some some milestones we passed
the 10,000 subscribers mark on youtube
and that is really quite cool because it
you know what it means is that the kind
of thing that I'm doing on this channel
that I never thought would take off it
was really my wife who who had to talk
me into to putting my videos of
classroom lectures originally online and
and you know my my questionnaire was
well who's going to want to watch this
but apparently a lot of people because
you know she was telling me I have I
have sort of a knack for being able to
take complicated ideas complicated tax
thinkers who people in trouble with and
make it accessible to them to sort of
bring them along so that they can you
know afterwards go into the text by
themselves or explain it to somebody
else so 10,000 view 10,000 subscribers
close to a million views so far for an
academic channel and not an academic
channel like common core standards or
you know the history channel but but
philosophy that's a big milestone for us
so I'm really happy about that all of
you who have subscribed thanks for
bringing us to this point i also have a
facebook author page and i've had that
for really about the same amount of time
I suppose and that past the thousand
subscribers mark just a few days ago
actually all this happened just a few
days ago so again you know for somebody
doing philosophy and talking about about
you know things ranging from political
theory to critical thinking to ethics to
religion and you know I'm not really
pulling any punches or watering stuff
down that's pretty pretty cool it's a
nice validation of what it is that that
I'm up to here so those are those are
some really great things that have been
happening let's talk about March so the
month of March was pretty busy and we
tried a few new things among the new
things would be we scheduled a quarterly
meet up we're going to do quarterly
meetups up here in the Hudson Valley and
down in the city we did one in March so
we'll do one in June so you know stay
tuned for that later videos I'll talk
more about that so we did one in a March
and a few people showed up I had no idea
how many
people would show up or who they would
be and it was kind of cool you get to
meet the people who are actually
watching the videos or or you know using
the material that I develop and I like
that sort of thing you know it's fun to
have some some face-to-face connection
rather than just video and comments and
emails and things like that so what else
I started doing some radio shows
collaborating with the punk-rock
philosopher who has his own I think it's
called spreaker radio broadcast Saturday
nights actually for me it's Sunday
morning because he's central time and
I'm eastern time so by the time that he
actually gets out at eleven o'clock it's
it's twelve o'clock here but he he and I
have been collaborating he he doesn't
really cool shows where he mixes
together classic punk new wave
alternative metal stuff interconnected
with some discussions about
philosophical thinkers and topics and
and you know he's more focused I would
say I'm continental philosophy you know
like I did some shows on niches thus
spoke zarathustra with him and he did
one on him last two weekends ago his
most recent one is on Dostoevsky and
then he you know he decides to blend
together different stuff so it could be
you know the police it could be rocker
chicks it could be love and rockets I'm
trying to talk him into actually doing
what a new model army who I think would
be really great for the sort of thing so
what else we had some events I'm
continuing the library series at the
historic Kingston library glimpses into
existence it's a monthly series that's
going to go on for the entire year of
2014 each month we're focusing on a
different existentialist thinker this
month in March it was
Daisuke so I led them through his
biography some of the key themes of his
works particularly the underground man
and we looked also fairly closely at
some of the characters in the demons and
then talked about the brothers cars maza
and then the discussion went all over
the place and ended up dealing with a
lot of things having to do with with
religion but that's the way these these
face-to-face lectures off and are so
that's ongoing we did a doctor sailors
philosophy for him and I did something
new with that as well which was I had a
guest come on and I'm going to be doing
this a lot more my guest was Caleb
Bonacci o friend and colleague of mine
who focuses on virtue ethics and we
talked about we compared and contrasted
contin and aristotle on the issues of
rationality and happiness so if you want
to if you want to see that if you missed
it the link is in the video description
I also had another hangout on air that I
put into the philosophy I flexions
because it had to do with Technosphere
stuff namely it was with Zachary Taylor
who's a games designer and of course me
as a philosopher we're trying to find
some common ground to figure out how
philosophy and game design can actually
interface with each other so that was
that was pretty cool released a lot of
videos during March a lot of half-hour
Hagel videos we're now at number 10
which will come out later this week I
did a few 10 shorts videos in that time
as well and a lot of videos from my
religious studies class this semester
religion in america and i'll talk more
about this i think another time because
i'm really considering what i want to do
with those videos they constitute
something like a course that people
could watch and learn from particularly
if they get their hands on the textbook
that that I linked to in in each of the
videos but one of the things that I'm
not getting enough time to do in these
class sessions is to focus in on some of
the
you know focus in deeper and in more
detail on some of the topics that I
think would be really cool so i don't
know i'm going to kick this idea around
I don't want to bite off more than I can
chew particularly well I've got the
Hagel project and the existentialism
courses still underway but down the line
i think i'm going to do some more stuff
with religion in america i've been still
working on a plan of course material for
the existentialism course I've been
developing for them it's going to be
available online it's going to be when
it's actually the least it'll be for
credit and it will be it will cost
something to enroll in the course but
you'll get weekly class sessions online
with me as well as access to a lot of
the material that I've been developing
specifically for the course so if you've
liked the existentialism videos and
you'd like to actually take a
college-level course and existentialism
with me you might consider that but I'll
put more about that i'll actually once
it's live i'll put a video sort of like
running through you know what what the
player no course would be like so let's
talk about April now um a little bit of
April has already happened oh I did a
radio show a theology matters radio show
I haven't done those for a while because
my thursdays have actually been
committed but now I'm going to do more
of those I didn't want an Augustine and
lying just this last Thursday so that
was quite a lot of fun would also be
coming up in April well if we're talking
about radio shows I'm actually doing to
theology matters one's already done the
next one is going to be at the end of
the month and it's on Augustin and evil
so we'll talk about the problem of evil
which is one of the deepest theological
issues there is and we'll talk about
Augustine's notion of evil as a
privation of the good so that's going to
be a fun broadcast that's a call-in show
so if you're if you're really
interesting that you can you can call
into that I'm doing some more
collaborations with the punk-rock
philosopher
he did a show last last Saturday on
Dostoevsky so that's part of what
happened in April he's going to do a few
more and I think we're lined up to do
some talk about Heidegger as well I've
also tried to get my my colleague I've
got a colleague who among other things
he's a really smart guy but he really
knows his conch well so I'm trying to
get him to come on the punk rock
philosopher show yeah that's a good
segue into talking about dr. sailors
philosophy forum for this month because
my guests will be that colleague more
Stern who wrote his dissertation on
Conte and I don't think he really is a
konshi at heart but he really knows his
Conte inside and out so it's really a
unique opportunity for viewers to get
answers about one of the one of the
people whose you know got a reputation
for being a real head cracker all you
know all field some of the questions
Morris will probably feel a bit more of
them but that'll be mid month that will
be April nineteenth this this week I've
got a conference that I'm going to st.
Anselm conference and i'll be presenting
a paper there on st. Anselm and his
views on marriage conjugal love and
sexual desire and you know connecting up
with old friends and colleagues I always
loved going to st. Anselm's if you you
know upper Pole of that if you haven't
watched my video on how I became sani
st. st. Anselm scholar you could take a
look at that it actually does talk about
the place sing psalms college there's
the felician ethics conference coming up
as well towards the end of the month and
that is down in rutherford new jersey
i'll be doing a talk they're also on and
some and i'm talking about something
called ontological dignity which is you
know if you believe in the notion of
there being degrees of being having a
higher degree of being having a greater
density of being means having a greater
ontological dignity and I'm going to
talk about whether justice as
you know opposed to say rationality or
life or sentient constitutes its own
sort of jump in being for an some I've
also got another talk that is you it's a
little bit more hush-hush they don't
like to publicize a lot and I'm not
actually going to say the name of the
organization but if you go to my
facebook page or you go to my Google+
page and click on events I'm going to be
giving a talk next week called before
they called it mindfulness and it's
about how some key ancient Western
philosophers like Plato Aristotle
epictetus we're actually doing some of
the things that the contemporary
mindfulness people talk about and doing
it I would say a bit better so might
actually encounter some some resistance
and saying that but that's what I'm
going to say and I'm going to lead them
through a few exercises coming out of
play dough or abacus or Aristotle that
they can then you know take home from
that that's a that's a dinner event so
if you're interested in that there's an
email link that you can you can click to
RSVP on um what else we're going to be
shooting some more Hagel videos this
month I think I might shoot some more 10
short videos because I have quite a few
questions people are asking me I've got
some religious studies videos too to
keep you know uploading with the
religion in America stuff I'm going to
try to get some existentialism videos
done because there are a few that i
really need for the supplier of course
specifically on Kafka de Beauvoir and
a few other few other things as well and
I will be hopefully a video recording
the felician ethics conference
presentation the saint anselm conference
we don't have a glimpses into existence
scheduled for this month next month may
we'll have two of those and we'll be
doing Nietzsche at the beginning of May
at the kingston library and Rilke at the
end of May at the kingston library I'm
still going to be working on this this
app lair no course which is taking me a
bit more time than I had expected but
that that's all right when you when you
do something like this you really want
to make it completely up to snuff as
they say if I have time I'll do a little
bit of stuff with learnist and curious
this month as well but I don't know this
is a very very very busy month we're
heading into the end of the semester for
my marist courses like I said I've got a
couple conferences to go to a couple
talks to give and doing some radio shows
so I'm almost looking forward to to
having a bit more time on my hands in
May and in the summer because we haven't
scheduled some of the things that are
happening yet but as the calendar fills
up then you know you see you don't
actually have as much time as you
thought so on that no I will end again
I'd like to say thank you to those who
have given me some some generous
donations you know it is a matter of
saying thanks for the half-hour Hagel
series if you like my stuff and you want
to contribute to my work feel free to
click the donation link we passed up the
the 10,000 subscribers and then thousand
subscribers in YouTube and Facebook
those of you who are part of that and i
imagine that almost everybody watching
this is again thanks to you and got a
lot coming up that that's really cool in
April so stay tuned and you'll see some
high quality philosophy videos coming
uh